search Google Earth for China and you'll
see this but an unedited satellite photo
might look more like this that grey
smudges air pollution and it's coming
from Chinese cars factories and power
plants but it's not only here in cities
around the world air pollution is a big
problem a majority of humans now live in
cities and that number is only going to
rise which means more cars more
factories and more power plants as
officials explore options for fighting
air pollution there's one tool that's
often overlooked trees cities are
centers of Industry but the resulting
pollution is filling our lungs and
making us sick one major culprit is
particulate matter airborne particles of
dust soot and smoke that are released
when we burn fossil fuels or kicked up
during construction and farming when we
inhale them they can cause asthma and
they can also enter our bloodstream to
cause strokes and even death experts
estimate that outdoor air pollution
kills over 3 million people a year and
as cities grow leaders are funding
creative and often expensive solutions
for the problem in London the mayor
spent over a million pounds
spraying city streets with an adhesive
that was supposed to glue pollutants to
the road and in the Netherlands
designers have created a giant air
purifier they call the smog free tower
which is cool but there's another
simpler solution a new report from the
Nature Conservancy shows that planting
trees could be a cost-effective way to
improve public health which they do in
two ways first a tree removes
particulate matter who included air
blows through his branches the
particulate matter settles on the leaves
and when it rains the dust is washed
down the gutters so we don't inhale it
second
trees cool temperatures by providing
shade and releasing water through
photosynthesis which cools summer
temperatures by about 2 to 4 degrees
Fahrenheit but there is the catch
trees can only clean and cool the air
within a closed radius about 100 feet so
city officials need to be careful where
they plant officials can maximize
pollution reduction by planting trees
were population density and air
pollution overlap the Nature Conservancy
report uses data from Washington DC to
create a map showing where planting
trees will have the highest return on
investment in some trees work better
than others trees with larger stickier
leaves like maples and Elms are more
effective but they also need to be
considered within
a larger ecosystem compared to DC many
cities around the world have even more
to gain from planting trees this map
shows where return on investment is
highest for reducing particulate matter
with proper targeting planting trees can
be just as cost effective as other
strategies like converting public
transportation to use less diesel fuel
but there is one major limiting factor
water access what might work in Boston
will be less feasible in a city like
Doha Qatar where water is a scarce
resource and on top of that many mayor's
don't yet think of trees as a public
health resource trees might not look
like giant air filters but that's
exactly what they are and the sooner we
start thinking of them that way the
sooner the air we breathe might be
cooler and cleaner in cities around the
world